[Music]  we stand on the brink of a breakthrough  in human evolution I have dedicated my  life to unraveling its secrets I take  risks that others would consider to be  unwise for I do not share their caution  over watch held back the pace of  scientific discovery for decades they  believed my methods were too radical too  controversial and they tried to silence  me but there were others in the shadows  searching for ways to circumvent their  rules freed from my shackles the pace of  our research hastened together we delved  deeper into those areas forbidden by law  by morality and by fear  new patrons emerged four possessed an  appetite for my discoveries  and with this knowledge what new world  could we build  [Music]  you